la empresa estatal de gas rusa gazprom
ha respondido a la pregunta que se
repite desde el 31 de agosto cuándo se
reanudarán los flujos de gas a europa
deberíais preguntar a siemens es una de
las muchas razones para prolongar la
paralización del nord stream 1 el
principal gasoducto ruso hacia europa
que moscú parece utilizar como
herramienta política el miércoles 31 de
agosto se interrumpió el suministro de
gas para realizar trabajos de
mantenimiento que debían durar sólo tres
días mientras que el 1 de septiembre se
anunció otra decisión
gazprom decidió suspender el suministro
de gas a la empresa francesa ngui
alegando que ésta debía dinero al grupo
ruso el 2 de septiembre
castromán anunció que se había detectado
una fuga de aceite en una turbina de gas
la empresa energética alemana siemens
construyó la turbina afirmó que se
trataba de un pretexto para prolongar la
interrupción del suministro
nuestra evaluación es que el hallazgo
que se nos ha comunicado no representa
una razón técnica para detener el
funcionamiento
un día después gazprom dijo que había un
nuevo problema técnico que afectaba a
una turbina el gigante ruso anunció la
congelación total del suministro de gas
y siemens alegó que nadie les había
solicitado realizar las reparaciones los
representantes de la unión europea
dejaron claro que creían que el gas se
estaba utilizando como un chantaje pero
es posible que rusia que como saben está
utilizando los suministros de gas y
petróleo como arma de chantaje corte los
suministros en el futuro
el lunes el pretexto de los problemas
técnicos quedó en entredicho el kremlin
dijo que las entregas no se reanudarán
hasta que se levanten las sanciones a
pesar de las sanciones europeas las
exportaciones de petróleo y gas
aportaron 158 mil millones de euros a
rusia en el primer semestre de 2022
permitiendo al país sostener su guerra
en ucrania